four fellows from Code for America have
arrived in San Francisco the team has
been picked from volunteers consisting
of social scientists political
scientists and IT experts Code for
America aims to improve relationships
between citizens and government
technology is an excellent way to make
our society inclusive if we design it
well and we use it as a tool to further
social inclusion and so I'm here today
to do my part
the fellows make their way to the Job
Center to meet Jason Welli who is
standing in for the director he explains
how job seekers data is internally
processed the fellows need details like
these to come up with the technological
solutions that are highly sought after
government really in the United States
doesn't invest a lot of money in
technology and in many ways users such
as myself and my staff have to maybe
work a little less efficiently than they
would ordinarily if they had
technological solutions to some of their
problems Code for America began three
years ago by web specialist Jennifer
pahlka she finances the project through
sponsorships by companies like Google
and Dropbox
every fellow receives around 26,000
euros for their work one of the things
that you see here in America at least is
that the interfaces in your daily live
now are beautiful and simple and easy to
use interfaces to government don't
always look that way and so not only can
we do it faster and cheaper but we can
do it better in a way that is more user
friendly prettier and just makes you
feel like you're part of something that
makes sense
prepare dot ly is one of code for
Americas projects it's designed to warn
the people of Austin Texas about forest
fires users can check the risk status of
their house online and are sent texts
when a fire is approaching adopt the
fire hydrant allows the citizens of
Anchorage Alaska to do just that people
who adopt a hydrant are responsible for
keeping it free of snow since 2011 the
Code for America fellows have developed
almost 30 applications they have access
to way of thinking and technical skills
and design skills that government
doesn't usually hire for and frankly we
haven't attracted those kind of people
to government back in the Job Center the
team determines that the computers are
in need of an upgrade they check the
software that job seekers use to
register
they conclude that the method of data
processing should be simplified what we
would evolved is actually to get a smart
app that directly connects our business
partners who employ our clients and our
jobseekers to where they could work
together online to help to identify the
job openings of the businesses have and
the qualifications and the resumes of
our job seekers I think that by creating
opportunities for people in government
to really innovate through technology
you have so many more opportunities to
to kind of work collaboratively with the
residents of their cities or counties or
other municipalities the problem has
been identified and now it's up to the
fellows to come up with a solution the
job seekers of San Francisco depend on
it
shift says put great ideas into motion